welcome to this video playing cupid 11
from from when I'm the some island in
the crib ixia Trinidad and Tobago let's
see a fianchetto Kings Indian ok maybe
he will go for a goon Felton yep yeah do
you take here or not who probably you
take them playing for them possibly good
porn structure with night a4 and yeah
I'm not sure that this is any good a
fighter basics it's not like he's having
some pressure against e2 don't know
yeah i can try to to get an e5 here you
five maybe here i am 22 half bushel f6
later okay I don't mind dad
especially I don't mind that but the
bishop on b5 that's always subject to a
text like a four at the right moment
okay just get this out of the diagonal
so that I have III at some moment
now i'm also threatening Bishop 65 just
just taking this
okay so this is this he prevented but he
maybe has Bishop F a town Bishop f8
before this is the scandal idea and it's
interesting
mm yeah let's that's not good but
irritating of this Bishop coming here
how to to do that now Bishop should I go
push of age 67 but you can take and take
e tool
ok don't like to play that very much
reitställe should be quite good for wide
yeah this is in neglecting the dark
squares quite substantially I can try to
play Bishop b5 try to get on on the
Kings side may be here and I just like
Queen f4f 6i are serious I mean he may
be must react to that
okay it seems he does not think you must
react to that in any way okay
check
yeah on an aquaneer 56 scandal idea that
it needs to hear hero really needs to do
something about f5 remarkable move now
maybe
hmm that sets it not so bad for black
quite quite amazing he's got the
complete Swiss cheese structure landed
on the dark squares but it still seems
to be okay fun I thought rupee egg was
better but I came so yeah he will get a
get with the King to to the pawn him but
it's not clear that this is so much of a
problem i have the a pawn to play
against and will win it I guess I plays
rugby said but then I'm invading with
both rooks this is this is certainly not
bad for me
yeah the two ponds should should decide
decide this black resigns yeah I don't
know this was a strange strange
situation here in the game right here
white should be should be in excellent
shape but maybe e6 Fisher f8 is a good
defense now it can it is possible that
i'm not not evaluating this right yeah
yeah be should have had this is ok Ferb
like maybe if he gets in this Bishop f8
move my rooks then feel a clumsy
replaced by bishop interesting the
computer wants to go G for dad that's a
very interesting move it also opens up
the third rank for the rook very
interesting and now it switches to age
for which was my move h5 check yeah I'm
playing all all stockfish share
interesting a five or so petite wants to
go III or bishop f1 with some advantage
not much 0.4 0.5 okay
yeah and here i thought maybe rook p8
but he went here and after that I'm
bettin we are the computer in Greece it
gives wide a clear edge now the a porn
is simply too too weak the way it it
happened it was it was pretty much
winning after this young that's plus 2
and so he defended well for very no time
but then after the the the bishop trade
here the pure double rook endgame is
very good for wide I think you also
could have done something else here wait
before instead of GV casa could play
here getting rid of the the sea pawn
yeah this is this is equal this is equal
like has no problems here okay thanks
for watching